long before the white men came to the
new world the American Indians
occupied the broad land we now called
the United States they were of great
people of many tribes some lived in the
desert others on the plain
still others in the forests on the lakes
and rivers their natural enemies were
numerous and in addition tribal wars and
feuds took their toll yet always the
Indians faced their fold without fear
their sons and daughters of today faced
new enemies one of them is a cruel
disease tuberculosis which steals away
the strength of the victim until he is
lifeless yet Indians of today have not
lost the courage of their father and
this courage will not fail them
this enemy too they will conquer
never looks back to the house of the
Dead
it is our custom that we live our death
in peace we will start anew who knows
just because a hockey are there is a BJP
for Jane I met in the game slow talker
is running we have always gone out to
meet our enemies but now no more now we
die yes we die but it is sad question
mother then your father died of
tuberculosis
he said we die because we do not keep
the old customers I wonder your talk is
brave yeah but he may be mistaken the
old weapons of our fathers cannot fight
tuberculosis do you mean we should heed
the right doctor I am loyal to the old
man
nema I have news I am going to the
boarding school yeah
is your mind really made up yes I honor
our people respect them but white people
have much to share with us I will learn
something and live better and you will
come back
goodbye NEMA goodbye Robert
goodbye slow talker goodbye
forsaken the ways of his people
the ways pot for these two comrades good
luck to you says Don as Robert faces new
experiences in school
it all seems strange at first but
Robertson likes it and he learns fast he
discovers the wisdom left by others in
books both mind and hand are trained he
learns the skillful use of tools and
machine order and cleanliness become
part of his daily life
sports and games help him to build a
strong body in pick muscles and train
him in the art of team play with his
fellows
boys the doctor has come to make the
physical examination boys y'all look
strong but there are the invisible worms
that can harm the body we call them germ
and so each student gets a physical
examination Robert I think I'll start
with you first ever thump of covered
water barrel to hear how full it is this
is just like that doctors learn how
lungs sound when healthy and when sick
we put the ear the ground here the
footsteps of the enemy is that so we
have the same idea
lungs make sound one kind of sound when
healthy another kind one sick stand here
please Robert
chin up their shoulders against that's
it
x-rays we call them the Rays passed
right through the body and throw a shout
a picture on the film in the holder take
a deep breath hold it finished now
tomorrow when this film is developed I
will show you a picture of your heart
and lungs here Robert is the x-ray
picture of your lungs taken yesterday
these are the collarbones the ribs lung
all healthy healthy all healthy but that
spot see it that spot is made by
tuberculosis Robert no tuberculosis but
I am so well I don't call it can't be
don't be discouraged Robert the lung
will heal if you go at once to a
sanatorium and stay there until the
doctor says you may go home and so
Robert finds himself in the sanatorium
where under the guidance of doctors and
nurses he learns to fight his enemy in
bed
is he alright it looks healthy he's just
lazy easygoing in bed ah
how long do you think you'd be in
hospital I don't know a long time maybe
the nurse says Robert must be quiet in
bed I told Robert he's assisting our
insistence were brave they stood on
their feet and fought their enemies
until they were quit what's this I hear
today young men lazing around in bed ah
but grandfather perhaps that is not the
way to fight this enemy on their feet
and they do they die done don't you
think you should go to the doctor no I
am strong
tomorrow I will be better hello robert
maillet down now that you're almost well
I'd like to tell you more about this
disease you can help your people better
than I can
to understand here's the last one here's
the right here is a wing pipe the lung
is solved like a sponge and it works
like a bellows tuberculosis usually
starts up here
it may seem harmless at first and heal
in a short time but sometimes it spreads
like a little patch of weeds
bit by bit it destroys the lung then the
man begins to call and spit up damaged
lung flesh it spreads more the man loses
his taste for food he loses weight
he gets weak and maybe spit up blood he
grows weaker and thinner and at last he
dies there's no medicine to stop this
disease no though men have hunted for
such a medicine for years but nature can
stop it and heal it as it yields other
sicknesses Robert what do we do for a
broken leg we tie it up with fixing
straps exactly why to keep it quiet so
it can heal doctors call that a splint
we canít I up the lung but we can rest
it by lying
quietly in bed and gaining strength from
good food that makes sense now will you
tell me again about that little
operation you did on me so I will be
able to explain it to my people it is
called pneumothorax that means air in
the chest here let me show you a small
hollow needle is pushed through the
chest wall air flows in the soft lung
collapses like squeezing wool it cannot
breathe it rests it yields when it is
all well again inside the lung is
allowed to blow up and breathe again as
before wonderful but here's what puzzles
me what causes that disease
he told me once before you is caused by
a germ but what is a germ well it's
really a tiny living thing some call it
the invisible worm but it is alive it
grows I can prove it to you
come to the laboratory
here in this tube is a kind of jelly
clean nothing on it
here's another something growing on it a
short time ago it was as clean as this
one do you know what that is
millions of tuberculosis germs a tiny
bit of spit from a sick man was smeared
on here and it was put away in a warm
place the germs grew like a field of
corn oh so in a few germs are the lungs
of a sick person get into the lungs of
another they start growing that's
exactly right and that is why sick
people should be in the sanatorium there
they can't spread the seeds of their
disease to others we fight a range fire
by clearing a strip the fire can't jump
now you see Robert why our people suffer
so much from tuberculosis they crowd
together somewhat careless about
spitting when people are not clean it
becomes easy for the germ to get from
one to another
some people don't eat right and they
become weak and cannot fight the germs
sheep dipping time from all directions
for miles around the sheep and goats are
brought to be dipped in a harmless
solution under the direction of
government experts this ensures a fine
healthy crop of wool everybody has a
good time everybody helps but the heavy
work is done by sturdy young men like
Don
slow talker
Don is very sick he has tuberculosis the
heavy work at the sheepdip started his
lung to bleed the doctor said I was a
good fighter I did what he said poor Don
he did not understand NEMA don't you
think the doctor should examine you too
Oh Robert do you think I could have it
anyone can have it it is passed from one
to another
I take NEMA
and the doctor shall examine me too so
you see Nima's lungs are all right now
we looked at your chest here is the
shadow of tuberculosis in your lab you
have added a long time but it has not
killed you you are a strong man stronger
than the disease then it is true that I
have given the disease to my family now
I know the enemy
I too will fight him with knowledge your
way
go my children I stay may you have many
children healthy and strong
for a fine baby you have grandfather be
so proud
loke Locker we salute you
the enemy has taken away your beloved
dong and Don's parents now you yearn to
go home to mingle with the people the
fields and hills and waters all be you
love yet you choose to stay you will not
bring the enemy to their fireside by
your example the people again will
conquer